*Music*
Welcome everyone to Kobo's milestone webinar celebrating our ten years of community-led impact and innovation.
Over the last ten years, you have taken our tools to the field and helped us create something better year over year.
Together, we have built an amazing community that spans over two hundred countries.
And today, we celebrate this community and everybody here who's curious about our work.
I'm Dev More. I'll be your host for today. So, here's our agenda for today.
We'll first start with our ten year journey, and Patrick will share about this journey.
And then, we'll have Tino who will tell us about some
recent product updates and about the future of the platform.
Then we'll jump into talking about our new offerings, where I'll be talking to Ayman and Paula.
After that, we have Tala from WHH and Sharon
from Save the Children who will be sharing their experience with the platform.
And in the end, we'll have an open round of Q\&A where we will
take up some questions from the Q\&A box.
So, let's start where it all began with Patrick, our cofounder and president.
Patrick, could you share a bit about the history of Kobo from its earliest days and the
journey on how we got to where we are today? Sure.
First, let me thank you, Dev, and everyone on the team for organizing this event, and thanks to the participants.
It's amazing to see so many people coming and joining
us in discussing where we were and where we're going.
So I really look forward to the discussion today.
But as you said, let's maybe look a little bit back before we look forward.
And not many people know that Kobo is actually more than ten years old.
It really started as an idea when
Phuong Pham, the other cofounder (but also my wife), and I were in Iraq.
\[Unintelligible\]
And we had a very simple idea. It seems so obvious today, but it wasn't the case at the time, was, well, let's ask people.
And so we started using what would be traditionally epidemiological methods to kind of assess
people's opinions and perspectives on how to rebuild after violence.
But in doing so, we realized that we needed to move much faster in order to be able to drive action.
In other words, the time from the moment we collect data to inform policies is very, very short.
And so we needed to go faster and that's how we created Kobo. And so moving forward with, you
know, a couple of years, we use literally the money we would normally use
for photocopies and data entry to create the first Kobo.
And I had a bit of a kick looking back at some of those pictures
because what you see there on the top right is the very first Kobo.
It's not Android. It's not iPhone. Those things did not exist. It's actually a Mio phone that
was running a Windows mobile application.
That is the very first version of Kobo. But what we learned from it is that it worked, that it
was really possible to collect data in the field
in a way that would allow us to move faster.
And that experience of Kobo in the field is what gave the name Kobo.
Kobo literally means transfer. It was really about transferring knowledge from the experience
of people to those who are taking action and building projects.
And so the next step forward was in the Central African Republic.
what you see on the right is “hotel Kobo”.
It's literally a hut in which you what you see there were those solar chargers and how we would be
in the field without connectivity, without any kind of access
to electricity even, and still being able to collect data.
And that's where we realized \- Hey. We're onto something here. This is actually helpful.
And we started having people asking us, “can we use it?”
And so that's what really led us to where Kobo
kind of started building.
It proved that it works in the worst conditions.
So then how did we build from there? And so we deployed in DRC, Uganda, Liberia.
And as people started using the tool, we made it publicly available, open source.
We just wanted it to be a global good. And then IRC, OCHA approached us in a partnership.
How can we make it better? How can we make it more relevant for humanitarian actors and
others in the field facing the same kind of challenge you're
facing and and for which this tool could be really useful.
And that's where over the course of one year, we worked on basically releasing
the first global platform as it looks today, leveraging open standards, access forms
with this partnership with OCHA and IRC,
making it publicly available worldwide through our public server.
And that's very much the starting point of the modern Kobo, if you’d like.
So that's the ten years we're talking about. And something amazing happened from that point
in time, which is that it took about a year to get the first million submissions. It took
another year to get five million submissions, another year to get
twenty million submissions, and now we've reached a billion submissions.
And the point is that we have grown alongside organizations like yours in both
understanding how to improve the tools and making it relevant
and useful for actors on the ground.
So, in 2019, what was up until then a project run by Phuong and I out of our
universities and across time and different places, we actually established a
nonprofit, Kobo, which is now hosting Kobo-
Toolbox and making sure that this original vision remains intact.
The vision around making sure that we provide the best, most accessible,
freely usable tool for organizations who need data to drive impact.
We're very proud that we've been recognized as a digital public good, even prouder to see the
number of people in this webinar, even prouder to see the statistics coming on the usage in the field.
And so, again, it's been an amazing journey driven by you.
I mentioned the one billion submissions. Dev mentioned the fact that we pretty much operate
or have users or people leveraging Kobo to
advance their impact around the world in every country.
And as you can see, the statistics are clear. They speak for themselves.
Yes. We have some users, very large users, who help us maintain and ensure that we can
continue offering the platform for free to the large majority of our users, whether community
based organizations, small local NGOs organizations for whom frankly,
KoboToolbox is the best possible solution in
in order to drive impact again.
So it's not just a gimmick to say that you named us.
It is truly the community. It is truly the experience, the partners in Uganda that gave us the
name, and it is truly through the partnership over the
years that we have been shaped into the platform we are today.
The functions, the needs, the way to operate Kobo \-
was all driven by users, for users, with users.
And you continue to inspire us in that journey.
And that remains very much core to what we will discuss next, which is what are some of the
priorities, what are some of the directions in which we are going.
This is a critical moment because what we know is that those systems, those information
landscapes on which we rely on are actually disappearing.
They are definitely under threat. And at the same time, the reality of the funding landscape
and the growing needs and the complexity is that in some ways, data is even more critical than ever.
The fewer resources we have, the better we need to be at
allocating them, and data has an important role to play in that function.
And so we want to be your partner in making sure that we are not building top down information
system, but really leveraging the community and more participatory
information system in the humanitarian space.
In other words, what we wanna make sure is that we are contributing towards this ability
to create the change from a community perspective that you as actors on the ground have the
agency and power to create that change.
So, I hope that you will join us and there are different ways of doing that.
You know, the forum is an important part where you can help first time users,
and we really appreciate all of you who are contributing already to that forum.
You can share your lessons learned. It's amazing. I mean, we have learned from practice and so we want to learn from you.
And so any ideas you have on new features, on improvements, on the way to operate, we're very keen to hear that.
Again, we want to hear from you. We want to listen to your experience and opinions, and you
should feel free to reach out to us with suggestions, improvements, and sharing your experience.
We're very, very keen to do that. I will repeat it again: “for users, with users”, is to me
critical. And “by users” because we continue doing research, doing data collection and
partnering with organizations like you in the field.
I'm very proud that a few years ago, we started rolling out the ambassador program, which is
really a way to recognize those contributors on the ground who are already helping each
other and kind of empowering those actors in their
reach and their support to KoboToolbox users.
And finally, I need to, of course, note the Enterprise partner that can join a
community of practice that is dedicated to large-scale
organizations with a wide deployment of the KoboToolbox platform.
They have unique needs and we want to recognize that and really kind of make sure that we spend
the support and engagement from our smallest, very local
partners all the way to our largest key users.
Again, I want to emphasize that this is critical to the future of Kobo.
We have exciting news. We're working on AI. We're working on so many features that
Tino and others will outline in the future.
But it is with you in mind. It is with your input, with your partnership, and with you
driving those efforts through those avenues.
And so I hope that you continue being part of our future.
Over to you, Dev.
Awesome. Thank you so much, Patrick. Thank you for telling our story and providing
such a powerful vision for the future that we want to create with our wonderful community.
Before we let you go, I had a quick question for you.
What is your favorite memory as you have navigated the past twenty years at Kobo?
I was about to go, and I have to apologize.
I will jump on a separate call, but I'll still be in the Q\&A. It's a tough question.
There are so many from really the creation and the rollout of Kobo.
But I would say that I'm still very active on the ground. And when I go to small
areas in Northern Iraq or in Ethiopia, and people don't really know or associate me with
Kobo (I've never been promotional in that sense),
They come to me and say, hey. “You know, we're using this great tool.
It's called KoboToolbox. Do you know about it?” Well, Actually, I do know about it.
And and it's an amazing experience to see how
wide the reach has been and how helpful the tool has been.
Something that frankly was created because we needed it, because we wanted to be able to do
that kind of engagement, to see that kind of need and
service echo with so many people around the world has been amazing.
So, again, thank you everyone for making Kobo the success it is today.
Thank you, Patrick.
So, before we continue and go to the next section, we'll run a quick
thirty-second poll, which should appear on your screen.
When was your first time using KoboToolbox?
I know for me, it was 2017 when somebody
from IRC insisted that I check out KoboToolbox's report builder for its
intuitiveness.
I wish you could see what I see, which is the numbers coming in in real time.
It's fantastic. Hundreds of responses already.
Oh, wow\! Tino: We are over 50%.
Alright. If you haven't voted yet, please quickly add your vote to the poll.
I realize as a panelist, I cannot vote, but I will select
before 2014, and I would be curious to know if anyone has done that.
That would be amazing because that would be the very early days of Kobo.
You will be surprised. Okay. I'm gonna end it. Here are the results.
Alright. Well, it seems to be 2018-2019
to be the winner here.
No. Actually, the year before that, 2020-2021.
Great. Great to see a mix of long time users and newcomers. So, yeah,
let's move to the next section
All right. I would like to welcome
Tino, our chief operating and innovation officer.
Tino has been guiding our product
roadmap and the Kobo team for many years now.
He will share with us some exciting updates and give us a glimpse into the future of the platform.
Over to you, Tino. Tino: Thank you, Dev.
Thanks, Patrick. And thanks for everyone for being here today. It's really fantastic to have
such a huge group from the Kobo community.
You know, the last ten years of growth and innovation behind KoboToolbox have been extremely exciting for all of us.
And as you can see, it's not just the organization that's been growing, but of course also our users.
We now have more than a quarter million active users and that's very humbling.
You know, we're reaching this pivotal moment, not just because of where we've been growing as
an organization, but also because of the features that are still coming up.
But first, I wanna take a moment to discuss some of the new and most recent updates that
you can now draw on and that expands the way that you can use Kobo to collect and analyze data.
Here you already see one of them. That's been one of our most anticipated feature updates
from the last year, especially for larger organizations.
Our Teams feature in essence allows well, teams and, of course, larger organizations to
manage larger groups of people that are part of their team.
So, you can invite colleagues, manage team members, and centralize data management this way.
And, of course, if someone leaves a team, you can remove them and thereby remove access.
Joining a team works this way. You actually transfer the user's existing projects,
which are then owned by the team, and any new projects, any new forms or data collection
projects that they create in the future will then be owned by the team itself rather than an individual user.
And that's extremely helpful so that if someone leaves the team, the owners and admins of the
team will always have full visibility and access and control over the data
that was collected on behalf of the organization.
For now, the teams feature is available through our teams and enterprise plan and, of course, through our private server offerings.
This also means, and that's really useful for many larger teams, that you have a shared
amount of submission and storage usage that the entire team can
access, so instead of having individual buckets.
And I know Ayman will talk about this a bit later today. Next, we
recently rolled out our automatic transcription and translation features to all of our users.
What that means is you can now turn your interview audio responses.
And, of course, audio is extremely useful for collecting open-ended responses from your surveys.
You can transcribe them into text in many different languages. And then if needed, you can
also translate that transcript into more than a hundred fifty languages using machine translation.
Obviously, manual transcription and manual translation are always options.
And, of course, you can use our editor feature to review and edit any of the transcripts or translations as needed.
That's extremely important because, of course, AI tools, as any other technology, can make mistakes.
So we always encourage you, and as you can see here, we sort of force you to review before
saving the transcript. Next, we built a feature to make it possible not just to
transcribe the audio, but also to do qualitative analysis.
You can go to the next slide. We made it possible to
analyze the data that you collect this way much more effectively.
So, we rolled out the quality of analysis feature a few months ago.
And what you can do with that is actually create additional meta questions about these open
ended interview transcripts, and then you can assign labels, categorize them,
summarize them, and whatever you need as a summary.
That feature in particular makes it much, much easier to conduct truly mixed method surveys.
This means you can combine the advantages of fast mobile electronic data collection with the
depth and rigor of qualitative data as well.
For example, you can easily add one or more audio questions to your existing survey just to be
able to record the why to a question, or can you give me an
example or give me an anecdote for that sort of data.
So, you can combine your close-ended, fast,
multiple choice questions with this open-ended data much more easily.
It also means you can do this without having to leave Kobo. You don't need expensive and difficult software to do qualitative analysis.
And after you've collected and analyzed it this way, what you see in the interface here, it
still goes part it becomes part of the same data table.
Your exports, your API \- everything already includes these responses.
So all you need to do is download and visualize it and analyze it together with the rest
of your dataset. Next, we also, a few months ago, added logging and security features.
Actually, quite a few of them. And we're really happy to do that, and we're
really proud that we've collaborated with you and UNHCR on this.
What it allows us to do is actually provide you the logs of when someone logged into your account.
If that was someone else other than you, maybe you've given access to someone on your team.
You can see exactly when they logged in and from where. For project history, you can also see
exactly when someone made a change and, when data came in, when the modifications were
made to the data, to the form, to the metadata of the project.
All of that is extremely useful, especially if you have a large, distributed team.
If you work in a lot of different locations, you wanna know who made what edit.
And so you can see all that. You can download it. You can export it for lots of compliance and
auditing purposes.
That is extremely useful. And then finally, we're excited today that Kobo
will officially be ISO 27001 certified.
That's extremely important for lots of organizations where this is a compliance requirement.
And what it means is for those who haven't heard of the standard, it basically certifies
and ensures that Kobo always follows the highest international standards for data security to
protect all private data: all
data that you collect through your surveys, and of course, your own personal data as well.
So, these are all the features we're most proud of from the past few months, and I think
they will make a big difference to our many users and organizations around the world.
But I'm even more excited to show you what we're planning for the near future.
For starters, the coming months will see us release
an AI analysis feature as you can see here on the screen already.
That particular feature will allow you to answer these meta questions we saw earlier about
open ended audio transcripts in a much more efficient and time saving way.
It also means, in our experience, it is more reliable than asking
many data analysts, human analysts, on your team to do this on your behalf.
Our new AI models that we're training for this purpose will automatically analyze the transcript
and answer all the relevant questions within seconds.
So we're building this integration with the highest ethical standards and in consultation with many of our partners and users.
We always, of course, design this feature to make sure that there's a human in the loop.
So as you can see, there's a button, for example, to verify the data.
And if it's not verified, you know that it came from an AI agent only.
That particular feature will really speed up the process. For example, you could now collect
hundreds or thousands of audio from open ended responses and then analyze them in a
single day or in a single morning perhaps rather than giving this to lots of
people to transcribe and analyze over the course of days or more likely weeks. Next,
our huge flagship initiative that we're working on designing right now is our AI powered form builder.
This actually will integrate an AI assistant for the first time, and that'll help you
give feedback, receive feedback to your form.
So while you're designing the drafts, you can get immediate feedback.
You can also use it to create survey questions based on your prompts.
And, of course, very importantly, we're adding a way to upload any existing indicators or
guidance materials that you might have within your organization or within your sector.
So imagine having a survey expert, a methods specialist always at your fingertips,
always at the ready to give you feedback, to tell you what the best way is to ask a particular
question, who might tell you to improve perhaps your consent question, and so on.
So we're training this AI agent. We're still in the early stages, but we're training that to
be very, very careful, not just to be as ethical and reliable as
possible, but also to use the right methodological guidance and training available within our sector.
And as a result, once this is available, I think it'll make a huge difference to our sectors
and to the nonprofit world to build better surveys much faster. And then finally, we're
working on incorporating more case management features in Kobo.
Our goal is to enable you to track beneficiaries over time and make longitudinal studies much easier to manage.
We've listened to many users who told us that it's extremely important
to them that Kobo remains easy, intuitive to use.
And so we're very careful about adding these quite advanced features to make sure it doesn't
clutter up the interface and doesn't make it hard to use in practice.
So if you're interested in joining our user research on this feature, we'd love to hear from you.
Please, let us know. There will be a survey at the very end of the webinar.
You can add your details there and check a box. So, we'd love to have
you and talk to your team about this more.
Alright. So before I hand it back over to Dev, we have lots planned for today.
I have a final appeal. KoboToolbox has always been, as you heard from Patrick, community-led.
We really depend on you guys. So, if you have any other ideas for new features, big or small,
improvements. I see some of them already coming in here today.
But really where we want to hear from you is on the Community Forum.
The Community Forum is built for you to share ideas, to vote on ideas from other users.
So, please, if you haven't already, do sign up to go to community.kobotoolbox.org,
create an account, and share what you have in mind.
And of course, interact with others who already have posted ideas.
You can vote on them and so on. Of course, the forum is also great, as you heard from Patrick,
for helping each other out, learning from each other, and
doing that also makes a huge difference to our many, many thousands of users.
So thank you to those who are here today who are already very active.
Our ambassadors and our community power users, we really love you guys.
So thank you for being a part of this Kobo community over the last few years  And, yeah, back to you, Dev.
Thank you. Thank you, Tino. And thank you for all the
work that has gone into making the platform what it is today.
I know a lot of community members will be really happy,
to hear what they heard today about upcoming capabilities.
And I know that our product team is really excited to work with the with our community
as we build these capabilities out.
Before we move on to the next section, I had a question for you.
This comes up often, and I also
see a couple of questions in this direction.
So, thought of asking you while you're here.
You know, so as you know, the platform is known for its accessibility, for its
simplicity, and for its intuitiveness.
As we work on integrating AI, how do you think that'll impact how
people collect data on the ground. Tino: That's a great question, Dev.
Yeah. And quickly, I think one of the most important things
for us and for many people here today is Kobo is a free platform.
It's not only open source, but we want to make sure that it is remaining a free platform as a nonprofit.
Our mission is to help many of you. So the most important thing is that we focus on our core offering:
Collecting data in the most widely-accessible way possible within
limits, of course, that's something we will never change.
All these new AI features, of course, they're extra.
They're additional things that we're experimenting with. And so, yes, they can make the
survey creation a bit faster and perhaps better in some cases.
They can make the analysis faster. And so they are added services, and we're experimenting
even with other ways to help you use AI for conducting questions and so on.
But at the end of the day, our roots are very clear, and they show us that nothing will
replace a human interviewer who can do face to face interviews.
Um , what we can do is make a lot of the other processes a little bit easier, a little bit faster, and more efficient.
And whether that's AI or just other software,  improvements, we we will always see where
we can focus our energy  Well, good to know.
Alright. So,  before we move to the next section, we'll have another poll.
And this is which feature update you're
more most excited to hear about.
Well, not surprising  AI is getting a lot of
traction. I mean, for me, it's definitely offline case management.
I think our sector deserves a case management capability that is
both easy and intuitive to configure
Alright.
Do we have the results? And here they are.
Thanks everyone for voting.  Alright.
Not surprising. AI-enabled qualitative analysis
comes to the top, closely followed by automatic transcriptions.
Awesome. Thank you everyone for participating. There'll be one more poll in a bit.
Now let's move to the next section.
Alright.
So, in this section, we'll be talking to Ayman, who leads our partnership efforts, and
Paula, who's a project manager in our Partner Services team.
They'll be talking to us about our latest and greatest offerings.
Ayman will talk to us about Teams and Enterprise,
and Paula will talk to us about partner services.
So, you may have noticed in the recent past, there have been quite a few updates to the website.
We've been working hard to gather feedback and align
our plans and our services to the diverse needs of our community.
So all these updates have been a result of  all that work. Now I would love to
welcome Ayman,  who'll chat with us about the team's plan.
Hey, Ayman. Ayman: Hey, Dev. Dev: Ayman, would love to get your thoughts on
how the new Teams plan came about. Ayman: Thanks, Dev.
As you mentioned, our community and professional plan are primarily for individual users.
So, with the professional plan providing large data collection efforts, there has been a
natural evolution in this community just to work more collaboratively, and we responded to that
with the team's offering because multiple users wanted to benefit from a single subscription
plan, which works well for organizations.
All the projects and data would be owned at the team level.
So, basically, if an individual member leaves, their work is still accessible to the team.
Of course, it comes with higher submission quota, six hundred thousand submissions per year,
and unlimited storage, which can be shared with the entire team
Awesome  Here, you mentioned a higher submission quota.
Could you share a little bit what exactly those numbers look like?
And after that, I'm very curious to also get your thoughts on if partners are
interested in operating in in many teams,
how should they be looking at our offerings? Yeah.
We're gonna start with the submission quotas. Basically,  if you subscribe to a Teams plan
on an annual basis, you get six hundred thousand submissions to be
used anytime during the year by all of the plan members.
So, basically, there is no assigned quota to a single account.
It's assigned to the entire team. As for using across multiple teams, I
Think \- the Teams plan subscription comes with one team, and this
one team comes with the ability to add additional teams to the original.
As you add more teams, you're really moving in the direction of the organizational use of the platform.
So, at that point, the enterprise offering might just make more sense and become a good fit
Then, that's a great segue
into chatting about our two different enterprise offerings.
Ayman, I would love for you to
compare these two offerings  Ayman: Sure.
We have basically two enterprise offerings as you mentioned.
The first is the entry level enterprise offering.
It comes with ten teams plans, basically built into the offering itself, and there is no
limits on submissions or storage for all team members of the organization.
And then we have the enterprise private server, which gives our partners their own dedicated KoboToolbox server.
And it can be hosted in twenty five countries or even in your own local infrastructure.
Gotcha.
Just so I under under understand this correctly,  when you mentioned
25 countries and local infrastructure, let's say a large organization
like CRS or IRC or Mercy Corps want multiple
private servers, let's say one in India, one in South Africa.
Could we make it happen?
Absolutely. Yes. As I said, we have hosting in about
25 countries, and we have some hosting options in our cloud.
And there we can do it on your own infrastructure.
So, basically, yeah, we can set organizations up this way. Dev: Awesome.
Thank you. and then could you also tell us a little bit about all the different
types of services that our enterprise partners get? Ayman:  Yeah.
Basically, the enterprise offerings \- they're not just the software to us.
Fundamentally, they represent a strategic partnership between us and the enterprise partner.
We collaborate closely towards their success.
So our enterprise partners have access to a dedicated customer success manager.
We provide thirty hours of time set aside for trainings and consultation.
They get unlimited access to the KoboToolbox Academy for any needs of onboarding or, you
know, getting new staff to work on KoboToolbox.
And it also comes with priority support within one business day
And that's just part of the features.
There's more. Dev:  Great.
Thank you so much,  Ayman, for chatting with us. And also thank you to
entire purchase partnerships team for doing such a great job at
taking care of our partners and making sure that our
offerings are aligned with the diverse needs of our community.
Thank you. You're welcome.
Now, I would love to have Paula over to chat about our Partner Services offerings.
Hi, Paula. Hi, Dev. Hi, everyone. Dev: Paula, you have such a
rich and fascinating background in monitoring and evaluation across multiple countries.
I'm curious what made you
join Kobo's partner services team.
Yeah. So I worked with Kobo for years as well, and I saw that many organizations around the
world are not using Kobo at its maximum potential.
It's very often seen that we're using very basic service, very basic data analysis, and
these team missions is actually work on supporting and getting the best of Kobo
Gotcha.
Thank you. Could you share a little bit about how specifically Partner
Services help in some of these challenges that our partners face that you were referring to?
Yeah. So, working with directly with the organizations that are working directly with
communities that need specific features or specific forms for helping them
understand how to better use Kobo and how to
improve what they are doing, being more efficient in derisking failure.
In our team, we have M\&E practitioners. We have humanitarian workers.
We have people that have worked directly within the field, so we have the perfect combination within teams that are working
directly with Kobo, that have the expertise with Kobo, but also have been working
directly with communities in the past. Thank you.
Could you also share
the different types of services offered by our partner services team?
Yeah. Absolutely. So, as Tino and Patrick have mentioned, our aim is also to keep
Kobo being affordable and also
having in the core that we're a nonprofit, and that's the heart of what we do.
We are also offering some services for big users and for partners.
We have four basic umbrellas. The first one is form development.
So, we support teams with the creation of surveys and, in general, the usage of
KoboToolbox, then developing custom dashboards,
research and evaluation, and also solutions that are tailored.
All of these services are tailored to the needs of specific
partners. Dev: Great.
Thank you. I'm sure our community would love to hear about a recent example
of a partner services project.  Yeah.
So we're working with the UN Women Regional Office
In the Arab states with this project that we call TrackIt.
So, what we're doing is, basically, they are working along the region with over ten countries,
over a hundred implementing partners, and they have
more than eight projects that have been tracked using the system.
So, we help them create the forms. We help them create the dashboard that you're seeing in the images.
And with them we're collaborating so for everyone it's easier to access the data.
And it's not only a tick box for donors or for the organization, but it's also an opportunity
to make better decisions based on the evidence that they are collecting
Thank you.
Thank you, Paula, for sharing
the different types of services that our partner services team offers.
And, also, just thank you for all the amazing work that you and your team have been doing.  Alright.
Time for our last poll.
And this poll speaks the different scale at which
the community uses the platform \- from small
NGOs to large international NGOs,  running programs at scale.
Give it another five seconds.
Alright  Okay. We're over majority have voted.
Let's end it, and here are the results. Alright.
So five hundred to a thousand submissions
is where most people are at.
Alright. Thank you, everybody, for participating. And now we are
moving to our Community Spotlight section, where we have Tala
from WHH who'll be talking about
her experience with our Teams offering, and then we'll have Sharon
talking about Save the
Children's experience with our enterprise private server offering.
So, we'll first start with Tala. So, Tala brings over eight years
of monitoring and evaluation experience primarily in
the Middle East and North Africa region.
She has worked for a range of organizations, from NRC
to CESVI, and then right now at WHH.
Tala specializes in designing MEAL systems and strengthening information
management for evidence-based programming, and she also has experience across
different programmatic areas, including shelter, livelihood, education,
protection, and nutrition with the recent
focus on the Palestine operations.
Over to you, Tala. Tala: Thank you very much, Dev.
Thank you for having me in this webinar. So, today, I'll be sharing our
experience with using Kobo in the context of Gaza, which is an emergency context.
So, in the context of Gaza: Gaza, as you all know, has
been facing one of the most severe humanitarian crises.
And over the past two years, the situation has deteriorated rapidly, with homes,
hospitals, schools, infrastructures, severely damaged and destroyed.
There's also been mass and ongoing displacements with over 90% of the population
displaced and often multiple times. And the humanitarian situation has truly collapsed.
And this has created a complex and high-risk operational environment.  And
some of the operational challenges that we encounter.
Could you move on to the next? Thank you.
Some of the operational challenges that we encounter include access and movement
restrictions, which truly limits our ability to reach people in need.
The ongoing bombardments also pose a serious risk to our staff and the communities we serve.
And the constant displacement is just another layer of complexity, making service
delivery unstable. The aid supplies are limited, which means that we must
continuously verify and monitor and prioritize our services.
And the population's needs are constantly evolving in this environment, and with that in
mind, our data systems need to be adaptive, timely, and transparent in order
to guide our response and uphold accountability and trust
So,
WHH truly works through local partners and our emergency response has focused mainly on
three sectors, including nutrition and food, shelter, and
NFI, and the WASH. Next, please.
And given the realities,
that we're working with, Kobo has become essential to our response.
It's enabled us to monitor activities remotely, especially when direct access is limited or unsafe.
It's also given us timely and digitized data \- data that supports our decision making.
And Kobo works flexibly, and the fact that it's widely adopted by
our local partners facilitates our work.
And, specifically the Teams plan, has added the structure
And the scalability that we need to sustain our operations.
So, with that, we've been able to tailor our
data workflows to fit the realities on the ground.
And this has been especially important for our verification and monitoring activities,
where Kobo allows us to collect data even in hard to reach areas or when there's no Internet access.
Rapid needs assessment also helps us guide our emergency responses.
And when it comes to expanding our network of local partners, Kobo has supported our
preassessment process for CBOs. Because Kobo works offline and on
smartphones, it's accessible to our teams, our partners, even in the most
challenging conditions. The Teams plan
has brought several key benefits that have strengthened our response.
The first is scalability. As our projects expand, we're able to scale our
operations without needing to disrupt our existing workflow.
Second, it has decentralized project management,  which allows us to host all our
projects under one organizational account, and preserves the institutional knowledge within WHH.
It also makes coordination between country offices and the field teams smoother and easier.
The third point is that the Teams management feature, which enables role
based access control, and allows us to align permissions with our staffing structure.
Because we have main coordinators, consultants, volunteers,
and data collectors, this fits perfectly with our structure.
This not only promotes accountability, but it
also safeguards sensitive data, especially in such conditions.
The last point is around having enhanced support from the Kobo team
themselves.  And maybe,
lastly, from my side is just some feedback and reflections on the use of Kobo.
And feedback from the field has been generally very positive, and Kobo is seen as user-
friendly, practical, and empowering to the local communities.
Looking forward, WHH would want to capitalize on
strengthening the team management to help us create a more structured and secure
environment for data collection and promoting the library as a
centralized space for standardized templates and forms.
Thank you, and over to you, Dev. Dev: Thank you, Tala.
Thank you for taking the time to be here and for sharing
your experience about the
platform and your ongoing work in Gaza.
Thank you so much. Now, we'll have Sharon
share Save the Children’s experience with our Enterprise private server
offering. Sharon is a digital development professional.
She leads efforts to expand and standardize data collection globally
within Save the Children. She has experience working across
both local and international NGOs, along with experience in CSR and digital
education initiatives  Sharon leverages technology to amplify impact.
She holds an MSC in Development Management from London School of Economics.
Over to you, Sharon. Welcome\!
Thank you, Dev. Hi, all. I'm Sharon Sagues.
I'm the associate product owner for digital data collection at Save the Children International,
and I'll be talking about our journey in using KoboToolbox as an organization wide strategic
tool for data collection in our programs. As you may
Save the Children works across the world, reaching millions of children every year.
Whether it's responding to emergencies or improving education, data helps us to understand what
works, where we need to improve, and how to increase impact.
So with thousands of staff and partners collecting data, we needed tools that are secure,
scalable, and easy to use. Why?
Because accurate data capturing is essential in identifying activities that provide better
outcomes, allowing us to increase the impact towards our breakthroughs for the most
marginalized and deprived children.
Before KoboToolbox enterprise, our data collection faced three major issues.
First, it was unsafe. Data was stored on laptops or in filing cabinets, and many tools used
didn't meet our data protection standards. Second, it was inefficient.
MEAL teams spent hours manually processing data and building surveys from scratch with little
guidance on what tools to use. Third, we had low quality data.
Too many tools meant data couldn't be easily shared or compared.
Paper forms were still being used, and the lack of standardization made analysis difficult.
These challenges made it clear that we needed a secure, scalable, and standardized solution.
So what did we do about it? In 2022, we launched our private enterprise, Kobo
Instance, exclusive to Save the Children offices; then, we started wide onboarding from 2023\.
This gave us better control over data storage, access to new features, and improved data management for our users.
We supported the rollout with onboarding guidance, data migration from public Kobo instances,
a form library based on the public collections feature,
and ongoing help desk support for our users.
For some offices, this was not only transitioning from legacy digital tools, but a full
transition into digital data collection from paper.
The transition wasn't easy, but strong internal coordination and clear governance helped us overcome those hurdles.
And within six months, over 95% of our offices were using our KoboToolbox instance.
Now, it's well embedded in our monitoring and evaluation, and
we have millions of submissions annually to prove this.
But there's no better way to express this than through the words of our colleagues who have
highlighted, for example, an improvement in their security and data protection practices,
effective time saving, and increased confidence through the usage of a standardized tool.
We can hear from some of them in the video upcoming.
Kobo is a magical and time saving platform.
Efficient. From our side would be data security and privacy.
So, Kobo is real time, human friendly
So, we are proud of the progress that we have made so far.
And while the work is still far from over, we have learned some key lessons along the way.
On the “do” side, we managed to tap into a real
demand for change from our country offices, which helped drive momentum.
We also had senior stakeholder support, which was crucial because having champions at the top
makes a real difference. We delivered clear and simple communications both globally and country
by country, and this helped keep everyone aligned. We prepared as much as possible, but we
stayed flexible to adapt to each country office's needs.
Then, we scaled up existing features, for example, as I mentioned, to create shareable
templates working with our MEAL community to build an organization wide library of best in class
forms for each of our thematic areas. On the “don't” side:
As a small team of three, our advice looking back is to not under-resource.
Rolling out tech at scale needs dedicated people and time.
We also recommend not to underestimate the role of local partners, which may vary widely, and
we're still working on the best way to reach them all.
And for us, the migration task was also bigger than we expected, but it was essential for a smooth transition.
And finally, as you know, data aggregation across countries is complex.
Digitization through KoboToolbox and the creation of standardized forms are just the first
steps in building a truly comparable organization wide reporting system
So, that's it for me.
Thank you for listening. Grateful to be part of this community, and here's to data that drives real change.
Thanks, Dev. Back to you. Dev: Thank you so much, Sharon.
It was fascinating to hear Save the Children’s journey from using
KoboToolbox so heavily in country offices in a decentralized way to
now, how it's being deployed in such an organized fashion.
Thank you so much. Alright.
So, now we will take some questions from our community.
Thank you so much for all these questions. And, like I mentioned, we will do our
best to answer as much as we can.
But if you're not able to get your question, we will be in touch
over email. Sharon, the first
question is for you. There seems to be a lot of
conversation in the community around how do organizations who adopt
a platform, say, KoboToolbox at a centralized level,
how do they manage to make it work
financially from a perspective of are you billing back,
the fees to individual users or country offices?
Could you share a little bit about how
Save the Children manages? Sharon: Sure.
Yes. We do divide the the cost of the whole
Enterprise package among the country offices that are using this.
This is and we do it in an equal way for all the country offices.
And, yeah, it's billed back, but it's a shared good, so we
we share the cost. Dev: Gotcha.
Thank you. The next
question is for Tala.
Tala, you mentioned that a lot of your
work happens through local implementing partners. Are there any
certain specific lessons you want to share
when you work with local implementing partners where everybody is
using KoboToolbox?
Yeah. Thank you. That's a good question. Actually, we try to capitalize on what
partners have and try to improve the systems that they already have,
just so we don't impose anything new on them.
In a way, that also makes their work easier,
and our work as well, easier.
So, the main lesson learned is really is just to work with what they have and improve the
systems that they already have, whether that be developing the
questionnaires or improving the questionnaires or the data flow and the linkages of
the tools and forms within their Kobo.
Thank you. Gotcha. Thank you.
Well, we have two minutes left. So, we'll take one more question.
Tino, this is for you. Does Kobo work with government agencies?
Let's say a government agency is running a project and they want their own
KoboToolbox server.
Yeah\! Of course. I mean, the truth is many organizations and many government institutions already do that.
So, many of your cases, they collect data with Kobo and then at some point decide for
data sovereignty reasons or legal compliance reasons, they need the data to be on their own server.
And so we actually (I think Ayman mentioned this earlier) support
235 different countries where the data can be hosted locally in our different data centers.
So, if that's a necessity for, frankly, for large and
complex use cases, whether that's a government agency or organization, that's certainly possible.
And we support quite a few of those larger ministries or institutions that way.
*Music*